that's fine yeah that's for them to do
that's how i see it but you're not gonna
tell me you're not gonna try and attack
me because i say i don't want her to to
be with someone that's you know
a certain whatever okay but we do get
attacked often i'm glad that you brought
that to the forefront yeah we do men do
well even if i hear guys say like i
won't date a single mom like girls freak
out yeah like why not for that i
i'm not going to comment on that no
please do spread yourself
dive into that type of topic so it's
just like
i don't know
i'm here for it what are you saying well
i just think like whenever men say they
want to have standards they're shamed
for it so if they say like i don't want
a girl that's fat i don't want to go
with kids i don't want to grow this like
like men will be immediately shamed
but but women can say i want a guy that
makes six figures he needs to be six
foot tall he needs to have this this and
this
he but
and no one will say anything i agree i
agree i agree i think women often have a
lot of like
their list their tick boxes but actually
they're not bringing much to the table
themselves yeah see i don't know see for
me i think that it's i hear what you're
saying and women do do all of these
things and
and a lot of the times i say i feel like
it's everything's in the men's favor
right now if you're
if you're on point
yeah that's a small percentage of men
a small shout out to us
but
i understand what you're saying but for
the rest yeah it's going to be a tough
time but if you're on point it's
definitely everything's in your favor
right now as far as the criteria that
women are putting out for themselves
because they're you're you're you're
making the pool smaller and smaller
you understand what i'm saying so with
the i don't want this he's got to have
that he's got to have this he's got to
do that yeah the pool's getting smaller
and smaller so the ones that
now have all of the
all of the things you've asked for
they've got they've got a broad spectrum
to choose from there that's why you
might end up getting hurt
well it's not conducive for families
and that's the problem is like 50 of
women over 30 are projected to be single
and childless
and like by 35 you you hit geriatric
pregnancy ninety percent of your eggs
are gone by 30. oh geriatric essentially
shout out rip kevin samuels for the
thing he was saying another day about
the over 35's and what do you say again
leftover women yep
i didn't catch it fully
being okay i'm not past 35 i'm 31
but
perhaps i could see why men might feel
that way about me it's not right i don't
agree with it
but i can understand it
i think it's it's somewhat true and it's
not it's not like a fun reality like one
day i'm going to be 35.
like hopefully hopefully i'll be married
but i don't know that yeah but
like i think it's honest at least like
guys are attracted to fertility and
youth
yeah but you can get the oh but it
depends what you want yeah because you
can you still get a relationship
i don't think you can get a relationship
of 45 so it depends what your outlook's
looking for you're talking about
children and all of the above obviously
your time shortening but as far as
meeting someone and having a happy
relationship i don't think there's a age
limit on that because you could meet
someone at
whatever age yeah it was true but like
according to dating apps you're um
like 50 of your options are gone by the
time you're 30. so if what you take the
same girl at 23 or at 20 and 30 if you
take like the number of matches she gets
on dating apps it goes down by 50 see
this is the thing
you americans you love your statistics
for everything we're dealing with we
have to take life into consideration and
some kismet stuff going on as well
because sometimes things just happen
we're not it can't all even those stats
are obviously there's obviously credence
to those stacks at the same time
there's still you know that variable of
life you could walk out right now bump
into someone and everything changes so
i'm not going to write off the ladies
them over over 35 just yet because
you know shout out my over 35 full easel
with that you know i still could be a
nice man don't let you know kevin break
it down it's still go it will still
happen at any time yeah but but is it
likely to the likelihood might it's
significantly down but it's not it's not
it's far from impossible that's true
it's far from impossible and like you
can bear in mind when you're over 35 all
the 20 year old where's the running are
chasing after you as what that is true
yeah that is actually true
no fiction so you so you have the
potential to turn the tables as well
and you know some of them will just be
looking for fun but some of them you
could potentially if that was the
direction you chose to go you could
potentially mold them a certain kind of
way as well just like men do when when
we have our second um our second go
around and decide all right it's not
worked out i'm gonna get my girl she's
23 and we're gonna have a relationship
now you understand so i'm just saying
that i don't i don't want to they're
over 45 to be feeling all down and
depressed right now so i'm trying to
help people out
but
it's not about making them feel down and
depressed it's about being it's not it's
about being honest but i'm being honest
yeah i'm a listen i'm the oldest person
in the room yeah so i've i've i've
experienced life i've seen things i know
people of all age ranges and i'm just
saying that it's not a riot for you i
know a lot of women of this age are not
a lot of women that might be single and
a lot of women that find happiness at
these ages so even though statistically
the odds are against you it's not
impossible that's all i'm saying that's
true that's true i mean if you if you're
in shape you're above like i don't know
what it is here but you're if you're in
shape you're above like what 75 percent
of women that's just there you go yeah
stuck yeah when you see some of them you
get like a banging body at their like
so it's it's not it's not the end-all
be-all but that's not that's but that's
the exception not the rule most people
don't most people don't age like better
what would you
established her from what you've said so
yeah
if you're a fat single mum over 35 you
better get to the gym right now get
yourself
get your [ __ ] pad
get your [ __ ] back get yourself in the
gym and help out cause if you have got a
banging body and listen there's some
women
in their 30s and 40s you see them in the
gym they're going hard on that step
machine they're in an incredible shape
they're they're getting in shape like
they're they're
their future husband just swiped up yeah
they're like yeah they're going hard are
they going to go even harder after this
they're going hard no don't blame them
yeah letting them carry on carry on
sorry i'll just say i'm just saying yeah
like i